hello this live broadcast
Kyah seek digital sequencing and bio
medical genomics workbench application
to liquid biopsy and bladder cancer
research presented by Francesco Liske I
senior scientist bio medical genomics
kyochon I'm Alexis Krause of lab roots
and I will be your moderator for today's
event we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
leverage and sponsored by kaya gen for
more information about our sponsor
please visit www.disabilitydenials.com
for at the end of the presentation if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
board at the bottom center of your
screen or use the ask a question box to
let us know that you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Lewis Chi I will now turn the
presentation over to him
hi everybody thanks very much for
inviting me to give this presentation I
would like to talk about to you today a
couple of applications that the whole
workflow of Kaizen allows by connecting
what we can offer in laboratory with
what we offer in the bioinformatics and
interpretation of the data so the agenda
today will be going through the
application of chiastic philosophy
sample to insights to liquid biopsy we
look at which solutions we have to
enable liquid biopsy applications we
will more specifically look at the kinda
targeted DNA plug-in performance and and
where how you can use the plug-in to
analyze this type of data and then we
will look at to a concrete case of
application to bladder cancer data and
how we can use the knowledge base in
order to classify the variants that we
discover in this application and then we
will try to wrap up with some important
take-home message so let's start
immediately with looking at how the
caius example to insight approach can be
useful for liquid biopsy application
liquid biopsy as you know is an emerging
cancer application because it's known
unknown invasive method to detect tumor
derived mutation and their evolution and
in some cases it can even be better than
the solid biopsy here I try to summarize
some of these reasons so if you look at
a solid biopsy this is the classical way
of sample a tumor from a patient with
the disease the tumor cells are sampled
directly however as you know the tumor
is multi clonal in nature this means
that you will only be able to sample the
portions of the tumor that you take with
the biopsy on the other side if you take
free circulating DNA from the plasma for
example here you will have DNA that is
contributed from that cell
that are shared into the bloodstream
basically from the whole organism so
tumor derived alleles will only be a
small fraction this means that it would
be very important to detect these very
tiny fraction but at the same time there
is the opportunity to detect and sample
the whole genomic variability of the
tumor because then the whole tumor even
what you cannot sample with the solid
biopsy will output in the plasma their
DNA so this means that in order to apply
what we know to this great potential of
the liquid biopsy we really need to use
a smart approach by combining what
molecular biology offers us in the
laboratory to a by informatics that is
designed to leverage this kind of
molecular biology innovation and and I
will try to show you how in these in
these few next slide so the first thing
that we care about is the connection
between all steps of the workflow from
the lab from the data generation to the
interpretation of the data and here on
touching on a couple of products that
kyochon offers for the sample
preparation like for example to KITT
to extract DNA from plasma circulating
nuclear acid how we can target specific
genes that are associated known diseases
using the targeted DNA panels and then
how we can analyze these data by using
the bio medical genomics workbench using
in particular the target ad in alien
Alice's plugin and then interpret these
data using the ingenuity variant
analysis or the qci in interpret so
let's have a look at some of these
solutions first of all the camp mini
loots is circulating cell free DNA kids
that have been designed specifically to
simplify the concentration and
purification of free circulating
DNA from plasma and this kid in
particular is designed to yield higher
yields and therefore ensure the
detection of low-frequency biomarkers
because in particular this key produces
more complex library during the
sequencing and therefore it does enhance
the capacity of detecting low-frequency
biomarkers in the data then the other
product I was talking about is the kaya
seek targeted DNA panels this is
particularly important because not only
offers a number of solutions to target a
specific number of genes that are
associated to your disease of interest
but in particular introduces the
unifying unique molecular identifies the
um I so called reads this um I
technology has a number of advantages
that I will show in a minute but just
let's have a look in this slide to see
how you and I are introduced in the
workflow so this um IR unique molecular
barcodes that are attached to your reads
before the target enrichment the sample
indexing and the amplifications this
allows when you sequence your data to
identify um I groups to map read
according to their position and then
group them according to their barcode in
this way the um I allow the generation
of consensus reads that corresponds to
the original molecule so your data using
um I will basically correspond to an
accurate detection and a higher
consensus of the original molecules that
you have in the sample before starting
the sequencing this approach has a
number of advantages and in particular
the fact that you can allow for
correction of sequencing errors and PCI
errors as this first picture shows so
sequencing error and amplification error
happen in two different steps where
you prepare your library or when you
sequence it and they end up having the
same effect which is a an error in the
sequence that you read in your initial
data using um I you can remove this sort
of error during the consolidation the
creation of the consensus by um I group
and the reason is that if a variant is a
true variant that you have in the
original molecule that variant will
appear in all reads that have the same
um I bar code but if that variant has
been generated either during the
amplification or during the sequencing
as an error then it will not appear in
all reads with the same barcode this
allow us to detect that kind of errors
and remove this error when you create
the consolidated reads another important
element which is an advantage of using
the umi technology is the fact that you
can provide a more accurate snapshot of
the frequencies of that variant in the
original sample if you look at the
bottom group or in this picture you can
see again that you have the the blue
star which is a true variant and the red
star which is a sequencing or
amplification error so if you
consolidate these reads you will remove
the red star and you will consolidate
all the three reads that have the same
bar code in this case 777 you will also
be able to estimate the proportion of
that variant in the very original
molecules that barcode identifies so in
the correct case using umi you can see
that these the correct variant has a
frequency of 33% one every three of the
original molecules but if you don't use
umi once you have amplified your reads
you will see it completely different
proportion because then the sequencing
error will have a frequency or 20% in
your in your read groups but the other
balance the true band will have a
frequency of 60 percent
so this means that in order to really
improve the accuracy of the detection
and the understanding of the frequencies
in the original molecules you need a
representation of the original molecules
and that is what
um eyes are designed for so now we have
we jump to the by informatics and it is
very important to stress that in order
to leverage these advantage that I just
showed in the use of advanced
technologies in molecular biology part
of your workflow it is important to have
a bank formatic solution that is able to
use that barcode and to perform the
analysis by doing what I just showed you
which is understanding how the reads
should be grouped and how they map to
the original molecules you started from
so the easiest way to do that is using
the decay ASIC panel plug-in in the
biomedical genomics work bench
it is very easy easy to install once you
have installed the plug-in a number of
workflows appear in your and your
workbench tools but also a very simple
guide that is the one representing in
this screenshot here and this is really
the the Gateway to analyze all your
panels that you have targeted using
chiastic digital sequencing products and
and the reason is that this guide offers
a single entry point into your buying
formatic analysis and most of the
parameters will be pre-configured very
easily for you the user doesn't need to
select anything but is dealing empowered
in modifying all the all the parameters
that wants to modify if they want to
modify the workflow
these workflows in the in the triassic
targeted planet plugins have been
designed specifically to take advantage
of the Umi technologies that i talked
about and to clean the data in a way
that improves the accuracy of your
results a very important step in this
workflow which I will only show in
highlight is for example the preparation
of the reads and the the training of the
reads if you look at this picture and
this is something that people working in
next-generation sequencing know very
well is that they a great portion of the
data that you collect from a sequencing
experiment does not belong to the sample
that you're actually interested into and
the reason is that all the technology
that we use the sequencers they all
require a number of adapters primers and
sequences to tag the samples and
barcodes which means that your
sequencing data will contain all these
information that needs to be removed in
order for you to focus on what is
important which is the DNA of your of
your sample removing all this
information is not simple and you
definitely need a bioinformatics which
is able to do that the training step in
the kiya sig panel a plugin workflow is
able to perform automatic trimming which
is capable to recognize and remove also
for example the read-through signal
which might happen for example when the
fragment being sequenced is shorter than
the read length and therefore the
sequence might include a read-through
the reverse complement of the adapter
from the start of the other read the
trimming in these workflow is so
powerful that is able to detect these
read-through even of a single nucleotide
so you understand how accurate your your
analysis becomes when the removal of
these unnecessary information is so
accurate in the beginning and then we
have a very important differential
filtering cascade in the work flow which
is targeted to filter differentially
different type of bearing based on their
size and this is obviously meant to
improve the precision of your result
let's have a look at what kind of
accuracy we can achieve by using these
workflow because all these
characteristics that I just mentioned
they have an effect on your capacity to
obtain very accurate results so in the
tests that we have performed we see very
clearly that we reach a sensitivity
already at 500 Umi X of 100% for
variance and have a frequency of 5
percent and for variants that are more
difficult to detect like those with a
allele frequency of 1% we reach a
procedure sensitivity above 95% at 2000
2500 X and in terms of precision we
reach above 95% in high confidence
regions at an umi coverage as low as a
thousand x as you can see in the green
picture on the right hand side so this
is to communicate the high level of
accuracy that these workflow allows when
performing your urinalysis and we have
benchmarked our workflow against some of
the most known software for somatic
analysis and you can see that our
workflow reaches very competitive
results in these in this comparison with
an accuracy of 94% for single nucleotide
variants and 91% for insertion deletions
so now I think that we can look a little
bit more in detail of how you can use a
workflow like this one
in application to bladder cancer so we
have performed a pilot analysis and this
is only a pilot because we used eight
samples and the goal for these analysis
was to showcase the workflow that we
have from sample to inside so we
collected a sample from tissue biopsy
and we extract the DNA from plasma of
these of the same eight samples using
two different kinds and kids the tissues
were excised microscopically from the
solid tumor as in a classic solid biopsy
and a high percentage of tumor tissue
was expected and at the same time all
plasma samples were collected within the
24 hours prior to surgical removal of of
the tumor so these ensure the accuracy
of the comparison it is also important
to notice that the tumor stage was
localized so the tumor was
differentiated by was muscle invasive or
ophelia carcinoma in most of this
patient so the two kids perform quite
similarly when we look at the the
recovery and therefore we decided to go
on with the newest hit the mini loot
which is specifically designed for you
to to target better the low frequency
variants and in these in these slots we
consider these measure that we called
recovery which is the percentage of how
many variants that have been detected in
the tissue can also be detected in the
plasma data and you can see from the
picture on the left hand side of these
lies that the recovery of single
nucleotide variant is approximately 75
percent on on all
samples and this is a very good result
if you consider that the the tumor that
I mentioned was was localized which
reduces the expected levels of Behrendt
recovery in the plasma the recovery of
balance for more complex balance and
instead is it's a bit more valuable as
you can see we have a lower recovery for
the durations and we have higher
recovery for the insertions and this is
obviously due to the complexity over the
balance we are dealing with then I think
in this application was interesting to
look at specifically the genes that are
have been associated previously with
bladder cancer particularly from from
our collaborators in Tuebingen so this
plot shows a map of the mutations that
have been found in each patient in a
selected list of genes only the genes
that have been previously associated to
bladder cancer are shown here in the in
a by row and we have the samples by
columns where there is a dot it means
that mutations have been found in the
patient the color of the dot refers to
the percentage of how many variants from
the tissue has also been found in the
plasma like in d in the recovery measure
of the the previous plot here you can
see that the level of recovery is high
for some important genes like tp53 K
Roth a trois be rough for other genes
like tsc1 some cycling's RB 1 which are
known to be associated to bladder cancer
they Harbor variants only in a few
individuals and we don't have a good
level of recovery from the plasma data
so we this is obviously as I mentioned
it is a very localized tumor so these
might partially explain why we haven't
been able to reach a higher level of
covering also for these important genes
that normally are associated to the
disease next I want to see how we can
use our knowledge base in order to
empower the interpretation of this kind
of result so what I've done next is
running the variants that we found in in
in our samples through ingenuity variant
analysis and you can see here in the
left hand side of the slide the workflow
that is typical in ingenuity variant
analysis so for those of you who haven't
been using ID a before I VA has a very
powerful workflow system where you can
filter sequentially variant according to
a number of very powerful criteria and
in these workflow I can show a workflow
filter that is based on the classic
known filters to remove common variants
for example retain those that are
predicted as deleterious retain those
that are connected to the biology of the
tumor and additional filters here in
particular I have introduced an
additional final filter that I called
pharmacogenetics because this is a
filter that I designed in order to
retain and those variants present at
present in genes that are associated to
drugs that have been approved in the
National Cancer Institute website for
bladder cancer treatment and this is
very easy to add it to the workflow as
you can see here I've been adding these
step by introducing the right drugs in
the list it is important to notice by
using these very powerful but also very
stringent filtering approach that we
still have after filtering through all
these criteria five times more variant
in the plasma data compare to the tissue
data on the left-hand side
so these big difference is obviously
worth investigating and obviously there
is the likelihood that base level of
false positive which is higher in plasma
because these amount of violent might
look rather suspicious but at the same
time there is a possibility that we are
actually doing what we are supposed to
do which is capturing a larger genomic
variability than the single biopsy site
can be and of course further validation
are needed but it's worth investigating
further what's present in the variant
and we have done that by using the very
powerful approach that is present in the
clinical inside interpreter so in this
slide I present a screen shot or the
kind of results that you can obtain if
you run those variants that I showed in
the in the previous slide through the QC
I interpret and so I have obtained the
detected balance from the plasma in the
biomedical workbench filter them through
IV a and then used QC I interpret in
order to highlight some mutation which
are particularly relevant to the disease
and classified according to the
guidelines by their actionability it is
very easy to do a workflow like this one
because the biomedical workbench has
plugins that allow to connect the
workbench to IV a and also to QC III and
and and this is crucial because it
empowers the interpretation of this
variant and you can see in this light
that although as I mentioned previously
we cannot rule out the presence of false
positives among the higher number of
variants that we found in the plasma
it is very intriguing to see that
several of these mutation appear to be
of interest for bladder cancer and
capture that heterogeneity of gene or
genomic diversity of the tumor that we
know is present in this kind of samples
so if I can wrap up some of these
messages I would like to stress that the
chiastic panel analysis workflow as I
showed in my slides show a competitive
performance even at our live fractions
as low as 1% and is able to detect
single nucleotide variants with a
sensitivity of 91.5% and the precision
of 97.9 to six or seven next I would
like to stress that we've been able to
reach a recovery of variants well above
70% for banks that have been identifying
the tissue and also called in the plasma
and I would like to stress that
obviously a high level of coverage is
needed to reduce false positives and to
increase their recovery levels as well
as detection of hire two more genomic
variability from the liquid biopsy
another role I hope I managed to convey
the message that a coordinated sample
twin side solution can help streamline
the workflow from the library
preparation to the variant detection to
a sensitivity and a level that is
suitable for applications like liquid
biopsy and finally before taking any of
your questions I would like to thank all
the people who contributed to these work
which are across different hygiene
divisions and particularly from the
Department of Urology of the University
of Tuebingen who are really the guys who
everyday have to manage and help the
patients where these data are coming
from thanks I'm happy to take any
questions
thank you dr. Liske I for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button once there's
many of your questions as we have time
for so let's get started our first
question is how do I access the site the
kiya sikh plant panel plugin so this is
very easy because when you open up the
bio medical genomics workbench you will
have a plug-in button on the top right
corner of the desktop application and
there you can see which plugins you have
activated all the ones that you can
download so it's sufficient to click
download on this plug-in to install it
and have it ready with all the workflows
available on your left hand side as soon
as it is installed
our next question is how does the
biomedical workbench integrate with IV a
or q CI i so this i only briefly
mentioned in during the presentation so
the the workbench has two plugins that
connect directly with the interfaces or
of IV a and the QC III so it's really
easy to call your variants with a
workflow in the bio medical genomics
workbench and then send your valium to
IV a for further filtering already
setting some of the parameters in the
filters that i showed him in one of my
slide and then also to send your
variants to the QC i interpret and get
immediately a link with the webpage of
QC i where you obtain results similar
similar to the screenshot that I showed
dr. Lasky our next question is what are
the factors that might influence most of
the detection in plasma of tumour
mutations this is a I think a very
important question thanks for for asking
it because I think that the liquid
biopsy has really a great potential to
making it easier to detect the mutations
in the tumor and also very importantly
to manage the follow-up of for example
residual disease that is present after
the tumor has been treated it is very
important however that the sequencing is
carried out with the appropriate
coverage and that you're of course
you're buying from Attucks is able to
detect accurately those types of
mutations and I hope I conveyed the
message that we have a very high level
of accuracy but definitely it is
important that the the sequencing
coverage is high enough and and
obviously the nature and the
characteristics of the tumor influence
the detection in the plasma because the
more localized the tumor is and the more
is difficult to detect variance in the
plasma because there will be less output
of the tumor into the blood stream
what kind of parameters do I need to
configure in order to analyze panel data
so the easy answer would be nothing
because the that's exactly what the kind
see targeted plugin has been designed
for to make it really easy for the user
to process data from targeted panel
sequencing into the bio medical genomics
workbench so the user will find all key
parameters to be already pre-configured
according to the panel that they select
in the initial guide that I showed in
one in one of my screenshots the user
really doesn't need to configure
anything other than selecting which
panel they used for their sequencing of
course the user can still decide to
change any of the filtering parameters
that I showed for example when I talked
about the differential feed during of
the different variants so the user is
still in control of what's happening in
the workflow but it doesn't have to
configure anything in order to
immediately start analyzing the data
what level of coverage are recommended
to achieve the maximum accuracy so this
is definitely connected to the wall
I was I was mentioning before and as you
have seen in our performance data we
show for some of the most difficult
application the highest accuracy level
when we have a coverage above 2500 x um
I what is very important to keep in mind
is that these coverage would be the
coverage after you created a consensus
read from all reads carrying the same
barcode in in the um I technology so
there is a very nice comparison table in
one of the handbooks of the chiastic
panels and and it's it's very important
to highlight that the target mean
coverage to reach this kind of um I
coverage depending on the input DNA in
your preparation of the library might be
around 25,000 x
and dr. Oh sky it looks like we have
time for one more question
how can you filter the variance you
called in the workbench through
ingenuity variant analysis so this is
this is very easy because well using one
of the plugins that I mentioned the ID a
plug-in on the plug-in you can
immediately configure some of the key
parameters like what kind of disease you
are looking at and then the filters in
IE a in the iba platform will be set
accordingly to the parameters that
you've set inside the workbench the
results will be needlessly imported back
into the workbench as soon as the
analysis in the ingenuity variant
analysis platform has completed so it's
very easy to carry out basic analysis in
these ways directly in the workbench
without the need of leaving your desktop
application however if you want to
design more complex filtering you can
click on the link that you receive in
the workbench and access the web
interface of IV a and then in add remove
modify some of the filters in the
filtering cascade liking the boxes that
I showed in my presentation
I would like to once again thank dr. O
sky for his presentation I would also
like to thank kaya gen for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through July of
2018 you will receive an email from
laborat
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon
goodbye thanks very much bye bye